et on va plus loin avec pierre picard
géopolitologue spécialiste de l'asie
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
indonésie hier malaisie aujourd'hui
thaïlande demain qu'elles ont en quels
sont les enjeux géopolitiques mais aussi
officieux derrière vous bien il n'y a
pas que la diplomatie chinoise qui
voyage à travers le monde on assiste à
un renouveau de la diplomatie américaine
avec jeu joe biden parce qu'en fait
depuis son élection finalement le
président américain est assez fidèle à
ses engagements et il veut donner au
peuple américain un nouvel élan alors on
va retrouver une politique
internationale américaine qui va être
proche de celle de john fitzgerald
kennedy qui lui finalement avait essayé
dit anne des petits conflits qui était
relativement coûteux pour la mairie
redonnant je dirais un espoir au peuple
américain il y aura les mots il n'y aura
peut-être pas les actions c'est une
stratégie à risque parce que à l'époque
lorsque les etats-unis se sont affrontés
avec l'ex urss et bien les rapports de
force était différent et le mérite et et
puissante aujourd'hui ces différentes
l'objectif pour bayonne c'est de
reprendre du terrain au niveau
international et d'occuper la scène
orientale mais à vie pacifique où la
chine est bien implanté alors justement
la chine ont entendu ça sa réponse ce
sont vraiment deux visions qui
s'affrontent oui alors clairement on
peut réaliser aujourd'hui que dans cette
période d'après qu'ovide espérer que aux
démarches une nouvelle ère cette
nouvelle situation internationale va
créer deux blocs principaux le bloc des
pays qui seront proches de l'otan et des
états unis et le bloc qui sera plus ou
moins proche des notamment de la
fédération de russie et puis de la chine
et puis nous aurons un troisième bloc
qui va se développer qui seront des pays
tiers africains ou autres qui ne veulent
pas se situer dans je dirais dans ce
combat dans cette dualité mais c'est un
véritable risque pour l'amérique parce
que si
globalement les états unis ont réussi
entre guillemets à gagner je dirais le
pari d'éteindre le communiste le
communisme pardon de l'ex urss il n'est
pas du tout évident qu'avec le poids
économique de la chine aujourd'hui
primordiale et de premier rang qu'elle
arrive aux mêmes effets donc on assiste
vraiment à un renouveau de la du
déploiement international des etats-unis
mais il est pour plusieurs années mais
il n'est pas évident que les états unis
gagnent sur ces terrains puisque en fait
les finances et il ya le mort
l'économiste s'est aussi bien du côté de
pékin oui pékin et l'asie du sud est en
général qui ont l'avenir est l'objet de
toutes les convoitises des états unis
aussi de la russie on peut se demander
quelle est la place de l'europe dans
tout ça alors c'est une excellente
question parce que l'europe sur ces
sujets et de par son histoire et
toujours été divisés en tout cas
beaucoup plus neutre au regard des
autres pays avec c'est une politique en
tout cas multilatérale pour certains et
pour la france et c'est vrai que quand
on le voit pour le cas des jeux
olympiques qui ont été politisée et où
on se sert du prétexte car c'est après
tête de la démocratie car la chine
démocratie et bien c'est un combat a eu
en fait où l'europe pour a du mal à se
passer si tu es et je pense qu'on aura
non pas des divisions majeures mais il y
aura forcément des débats intenses au
sein de l'union européenne pour savoir
comment on se positionne ses 7 ans est à
cause de la division au sein de l'union
européenne qu'on aura du mal à se
positionner vous dites en europe oui en
partie et je pense que c'est une des
stratégies de l'administration balden
signer son point de vue est peut-être
bonne mais peut-être pas au regard de
l'état du monde parce que effectivement
eu secret en opposant à la chine où un
régime important c'est en fait s'allier
des pays partenaires qui eux mêmes en
fait c'est diviser pour régner donc nous
sommes confrontés nous en europe un
choix crucial savoir continuez nous
partenariat avec
les etats unis d'amérique à condition
qu'il n'y ait pas des conditions dès que
ceux de lois extraterritoriales qu'ils
soient trop forte tout en or seulement
ménages en mai en poursuivant notre
coopération avec l'ensemble des pays
pacifiques et avec la chine
aujourd'hui clairement quels sont les
appuis de l'europe dans la région alors
les appuis de rock sont nombreux si on
parle de la commune vont dire de la
région asie pacifique
mais c'est surtout deux régions qui
étaient dominés auparavant par les états
unis et aujourd'hui où la chine s'est
considérablement à planter outre le
continent africain donc les tirs et les
étasuniens auront beaucoup de
difficultés sur le plan économique parce
que c'est l'argent la guerre à s'imposer
en cette région et au risque d'avoir des
débats et des épisodes géopolitique
houleux n'oublions pas que à l'époque de
john fitzgerald kennedy on avait évité
une crise majeure notamment à cuba bien
effectivement on va vivre des moments
dans cette nouvelle ère des états unis
et de la chine développement j'irai pas
palpitant mais parfois un petit peu
préoccupants un manière question
aujourd'hui vous voyez
différence majeure entre le style trump
la stratégie en tout cas le style ça
c'est sûr eu mais la stratégie dans le
fond de trump et la stratégie
aujourd'hui de l'administration maiden
en fait 30 à essayer de sur les mêmes
mobile c'est les mêmes motifs de
rassurer le jir et là la classe
populaire mais 30 fait la même chose
mais avec une communication beaucoup
plus moderne mais aujourd'hui il veut
donner un idéal à l'amérique de mon
point de vue il eût mieux valu qu'il
coopère avec l'ensemble des pays du
monde merci beaucoup pierre picard
d'avoir avec nous avoir apporté votre